with more than a thousand confirmed
cases of corona virus the outbreak at
that Tonia's meat processing plant has
now become the biggest in germany's most
populous state and with the situation
worsening the military has been called
in to help test plant workers all of the
company's 6,500 employees are now in
quarantine and about a half have been
tested the district commissioner says
they're working around the clock to get
the situation under control
the highest priority in the district of
gooders law remains the prevention of
any further spread of the virus and to
avoid a shutdown super common
authorities have complained however that
the operators of Europe's largest meat
processing plant have been making their
job difficult by not providing relevant
employee information the head of the
crisis management team says he's lost
all faith in the meatpacking company I
want to say clearly that the trust we
have an attorney's company is zero I
have to say this clearly that statement
prompted a response from the owner of
the plant Clemmons 10 years he said his
firm had struggled to collect the
personal data of employees and
contractors Noella form and truly I can
only offer my complete apologies and I
give my apology because we are the cause
of the issue and carry full
responsibility me is a businessman and
the company is a holes in schizont
authorities now have the information
needed to properly trace many of those
infected mobile testing units have began
visiting private residences in the
region to test for further spreading
many people in the local community are
unnerved and frustrated with the ongoing
situation this is serious it's
catastrophic we'll all just have to
suffer again we don't know for sure
town's coming and whither all will
affect us it's not nice
could be that they should have started
testing earlier with so many people
working there don't know with the
situation threatening to spiral out of
control authorities have closed the
factory for 14 days for more on this
story I'm joined in the studio by DW
political correspondent Kate Brady okay
thanks for coming in this isn't the
first time there's been a corona virus
outbreak at a slaughterhouse in Germany
how can this keep happening well this
comes down to or has been attributed so
far to some of the cramped working
especially living conditions that many
of these workers have to live in most of
these employees at Tania's and many
other slaughterhouses as well
particularly in western parts of Germany
are migrants contract workers from
Bulgaria and Romania and these living
conditions that many employees have to
put up with is it's no secret that it's
something that's been discussed time and
time again by local authorities and a
national level here in Germany as well
but the meat processing industry in
Germany is so powerful and a lot of the
the firms say that they need these
contract workers to keep meat prices low
in Germany and so far that's how they've
been able to pretty much turn a blind
eye to some of these issues that are
that we're seeing in the accommodation
for these migrants and how is this
affecting the coronavirus numbers here
in Germany well what we've seen just
yesterday was the reproduction rate jump
again here in Germany it's now at one
point seven nine and that's being
attributed the Robert Koch Institute
says that's the Public Health Institute
here in Germany due to these outbreaks
that we're seeing only at the
slaughterhouses in western Germany but
we've also had some cluster infections
even here in the capital in Berlin as
well seven locations in the southern
part of Berlin now been quarantined -
they're about halfway through their
quarantine so so far though the Public
Health Institute has said that this
isn't something we need to be too
worried about and at the moment the
number of new cases nationwide is still
relatively low up well you mentioned
that these working conditions are quite
what do we expect will happen to prevent
this from continuing or there more cases
like this continuing well so far the six
and a half thousand employees at Aeneas
meat processing firm they've all been
quarantined but at the same time there's
also other people who don't work at the
meat processing firm they who live
nearby they've also been quarantined
because they live in the same apartment
buildings and the state government
cabinet in the state of North
rhine-westphalia where this outbreak is
in western Germany the cabinet is
meeting today to discuss whether they
need to have a wider quarantine put in
place so at the moment it seems that it
has been contained to the employees at
this meat processing firm but of course
there are fears that you know are these
people going to abide by the quarantine
there's been fences put up in some
places to try and keep people within
their quarantines but of course you know
emotions are running high it's not
something that people necessarily want
to abide by we've got another hot week
coming up in Germany as well
particularly in that part of Germany and
these are not conditions that people
want to be kept in at the best of times
let alone under quarantine
yeah no no one wants to be indoors and
all right well Kate Brady thanks very
much bring up to speed it's what I'm
sure will be keeping a close eye on this
story